put your w up for worth it time with
your watches
worth it watches worth it watches
this is the show where we re-watch old
worth episodes and give
behind-the-scenes commentary from your
shirley and adam behind the camera
before we talk about what we're watching
i did dig through the comments
recently yeah found some suggestions of
what this show
could be called i'll read them to you i
wanna hear what you think
okay what do you think about worth it
reheated
worth it reheat it
okay not not the best workout comment i
don't like that because it implies that
i lost my heat which i never did
okay straight fire what about worth it
rest stop
where the rest stop i actually like that
a lot
don't need a rest if you stay rested you
don't need to get rested
that's that's my life motto okay i have
a few more so let's just go through this
real quickly
watch it watch it that's pretty good
yeah sounds like we're scolding people
though what about
worth it sizzle me with your zest that
wasn't a suggestion but that's uh
pretty good i like that one and then the
one last option
is worth it back four seconds back for a
second that was the favorite in the
comments that was pretty good
adam what are we watching today we're
looking at the
five least expensive foods you've eaten
on the show
heyo so there's a two-way tie
for a number for fifth place okay
so we'll just go with the first one
which is
donut okay so this looks like we're in
season two of the show
we're eating donuts these were
incredible yeah by the way
and uh behind the scenes here they
actually still send us donuts to this
day
to this day wow the coffee is more
expensive than the donut
you know what it's good coffee donuts
are really hard to make
yeah they seem like such a commonplace
food but
the amount of time and effort that goes
into making these things is really
incredible
the thing is i think if you make one
donut that's a lot of time you make a
lot of donuts it's
like around the same amount of time
right it's not like they scale very
easily
and we drove all the way up to where is
it calabasas
around there woodland hills yeah
woodland hills
and eight three donuts in one day this
is the notorious
episode that made us stop eating all the
donuts or foods in one day
yeah the sugar high and crash was very
real this day i felt
very sick by the end of the day i
remember adam was like
begging for us to stop to get a fried
chicken sandwich at the last place
because he was like i need
i need some real food i need something
other than sugar yeah
next up also tied for fifth place cookie
so this is a good example of a location
that is in our least expensive tier
but is in actuality a pretty expensive
bakery
yeah i mean the item that we got is
actually the cheapest thing you can buy
at this right place it's kind of a fun
game that we get to play with the show
where
the least expensive food is not always
at
a kind of inexpensive place
you know there's adverse works yeah it
shows that like there's value to be
found everywhere you know
we also find really expensive foods at
very
a hole in the wall type establishment so
it goes both ways
i do like that we're covering the
cheapest foods that we've covered
because
the show is secretly about
the low and middle tier restaurants
totally
typically most of you viewers out there
are not eating those on a day-to-day
basis yeah it's all about this
the expensive ones are like the
cornerstone that you can base the
episode around but then
the cheap and middle tier is where we
get to have fun and like
constructing a different narrative so i
think like
the one dollar cookie at a pretty
expensive bakery
is an interesting perspective on
inexpensive cookies
because you could get inexpensive
cookies anywhere yes
you'd be surprised actually it's hard to
find a one dollar cookie out there
yeah this cookie just was the
total smell and taste of butter in a
wafer
oh why am i so bad at eating
it's a crumbly cookie it is it is
but you're good at eating weirdly it's a
weird skill
i don't know how you do it i don't think
it's that weird you know
i think most people develop that pretty
early on in life
do you ever watch old worth it videos on
your own time
sometimes yeah i typically try not to
because
thanks adam because i don't
like watching myself but when i do watch
this i'm like wow i can taste the cookie
like the taste memory is real yeah
i yeah it makes me i'm surprised how
often
watching the show makes me want the food
like i actually start getting
hungry off of watching myself
eat something which feels kind of weird
yeah
so next up we have a three-way tie for
second place
okay and all three of them are 100 yen
okay so we're in japan so with the
conversion rate 100 yen
it comes just under one dollar
oh okay the first one tied for second
place
is the egg
first egg in japan okay so we're at the
first egg location in our japan
eggs video we're having the egg
roll at tsukiji fish market yes murutake
so good also i know this is not part of
the least expensive thing but
looking at this scene it does not look
hot no
but it was really hot it was ripping hot
how do you convey hotness
this might be the most complicated
process for a one
dollar dish for real and considering
it's
two ingredients right it's the egg and
the dashi
i think i don't know if it's in the
video but i think these people who are
making the eggs have to have been
working for a certain amount of time
like six months
yeah they can even get to the next step
of being able to do the flipping
this was actually a very sweet tasting
thing
yeah were you surprised very surprised
yeah i was expecting
you know an omeletty thing and it was
more of a
sweet custardy theft definitely one of
the most unique things you could get for
a dollar
or i guess slightly less than a dollar
okay next up
tied for second place
coffee coffee coffee
okay i might take back what i said about
complicated processes
because this actually is more
complicated than that egg yeah because
they source their beans and they weigh
them out
and then they combine them in certain
proportions
in an off-site location where then they
are testing them refrigerating them for
sure
send them to the to the uh each
individual location
there's like actual science happening
there they had like a thing where they
would brew a little bit and then put it
in this like
spectrometer not a spectrometer but you
know like something that was measuring
like the acidity
and the something and then all this
crazy stuff
i remember um you know how there's like
uh
like the color spectrum i remember i do
i remember the color spectrum
yeah just in general yeah okay he had a
diagram next to the roasting machine
that was a spectrum of smells and then
like
flavor qualities there was like a
spectrum of roasting
doneness and then the smell and
flavor associated with it as like a
cheat sheet
and there was like a hundred variations
on there it was awesome
i didn't see that oh right there right
there yeah there's the spectrum oh hell
yeah
so they've got this machine where
because we're having the iced coffee in
the episode
they have a machine that brews it hot
but then dispenses it
cold like instantly
and so you can see the condensation
going up the
jar there that was a thing this metal
canister you can see the condensation
going up that was the thing i remember
filming like oh yeah
um i gotta like zone in while this thing
creeps up
or like i saw it happening the first
time and then i missed it and i was like
damn it
i'll never be able to film that again
and then he started making another one
and then i swooped in
the last one tied for second place sushi
sushi
100 yen sushi
i feel like conveyor belt sushi things
are one of those
uh like restaurants that you feel like
you might not
have to go to if you go to japan because
it's like
oh i'd rather go to a more expensive
sushi place but this was
honestly so much fun and such a unique
experience i
i highly recommend it can you imagine
like being in high school and going
here after school like
come on come on least expensive
food you've ever eaten under the
dumplings also one of the most recent
foods we've ever eaten on worth it
so there's actually three dumplings that
are
the bottom one
the chive the cabbage and the pork look
at that the cabbage
so good i don't want to wash this
anymore it's torture
we're getting dumplings for lunch but
we're not gonna get these dumplings
i know oh
no i knew this was gonna happen i
haven't watched this episode since aired
can we just stop the the video here i
don't wanna watch my hair watching this
this is definitely one of those foods
that i
regret the most that i can't have access
to on a regular basis
uh we need to go back i do appreciate
though that there have been some fans
who have gone here
yeah and tagged us and stuff i don't
know if you check your uh
story tags i check them from time to
time and uh i'm like
always very happy to see people go to
this restaurant for sure
restaurant she was a treat she was just
a delightful human being just so
friendly
just a mom that's making that a mom that
you can buy food from
let's get to the buns pork cabbage
look at the bottom the taste oh my god
that's my favorite along this episode
the hi
i'm crispy
that was not a performed reaction right
no i mean like you didn't that was like
how giddy we were
eating those things when you're in
taiwan
and you eat buns i remember the chive
was surprisingly fishy
didn't make the cut but it had a
surprisingly strong fish flavor to it
the least expensive foods tend to be our
actual favorites on the show
and that's because we always try to find
great restaurants and so
if it's great and it's the least
expensive it's
usually got a lot of credit in its favor
to be the worth it winner okay so thanks
for watching this
worth it watching worth it so we
actually have new
worth it episodes airing right now uh
check them out
sunday morning we've got double
cheeseburger if you haven't seen it yet
go check it out and next week we got
noodles bye
you